Let's go next to Caitlyn from
Niagara. Caitlyn, you're on the air.
I can hear me. Yes, I can. Hi,
thanks for taking my call. Thank you.
I'm interested in the security
around the state capital
and I'm kind of wondering why it's still there
and how long it would stay for which state which
state capitol you're seeing in New York where
you are. No, I'm actually this is the Washington
state capitol. I'm actually in Canada, Niagara
Washington State or Washington, D.C., D.C. sort.
Oh, OK. All right. So the the the Capitol, the
federal Capitol, you're concerned about how
long they're going to stay there? Yeah, I I've
been people have been emailing me about this. I
don't know the answer. I mean, you know, this
week they were supposedly still there because
March 4th was the day when Trump was going to
supposedly become president again, according to
some Kuhnen people. I don't know. I mean, like on
the record, what they're supposedly there for is
just a disincentive is anything like even trying
anything like what went down on January six.
But a certain point, you got to start paring it
down, you know, and that was part of my question
is that do you think they would the administration
or whoever is in charge of keeping them there
would keep them there as an optic to say that
this part of the right wing is a dangerous threat.
And if everybody sees the security around
it continuing on throughout the year,
they will continue to think, OK, maybe there
is a continued threat to the building or to
whatever they're trying to dissuade. Yeah,
I mean, it could more be optics as well.
I think you could be right. The
problem is that there's also, you know,
the right is pointing to it and saying
this is Joe Biden's police state America,
and they're building antipathy by it. So I don't
know that the optics are necessarily all good.
Yeah, that makes sense, although I don't think
they would think about it in that way. Yeah, it
seems like they're more thinking about it inside
of their own framework. I think you're right.
And what the other side thinks, everybody will
see it for what they want it to be. My view is I
understand why it why it started on January 6th,
although a few hours too late. And I'd love to
have a sense of what the plan is and for how long
this is going to be the status quo in Washington.
Do you think they were embarrassed that they
weren't ready for January six and then you agree?
Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, OK, well, thank you
for taking my call. I really appreciate
it. It's the first time calling in and
I appreciate appreciate your program.
Thank you so much. Kalyn from Niagara,
very much. Appreciate it. Let's take a quick
break. If you are holding on discord. Don't
hang up because we are going to take
more calls after this very short break